Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier and welcome back to Enter The Gungeon.
I just couldn't stop playing at first one. It is ridiculously
awesome and I need to show off a little bit of skill here.
Woah hey ho ho OH GOD!
Noooo ho ho!
OH I thought I was dead!
Ha ha ha I thought I was so dead.
Oh man. So I ... I'm playing with
the mouse and keyboard right now, and holy crap.
Hup. Boink! Okay
This is gonna be... this... this is awfully powerful for one shot
But I don't know if I need this for the-
Oh, god damn it!
[chuckles]
Thankfully, it seems to be a bit forgiving, but how do I switch--
OOOHHHH.
OH THERE WE GO!
OH my crossbow!
I've got hunter's crossbow or something like that.
OH that's COOL -- ohh that's really cool :D
Okay, so this is my special thing that my hunter has--
Hello, stop that. You stop that right now.
Thank you!
You stop that - Nope!
I'm playing with the mouse and keyboard now,
which is actually way, WAY easier than playing with the controller
because it was very hard to aim... with the controller
Sorry!
I'm sorry -- Whoa!
-mumbling- sorry gotta play better!
Playing like crap!
DUH DUH DUH DUH!!
HUPERB!
Ahhhh BAH BAM BAHM BAH BAH BAAAAHH
HABOOSKY!
God dammit with the reload on this guy-
WOOOOOO what're you doing?
Ghost? Where'd that ghost with a gun come out of nowhere?
HA BAHABAHABAABAH
HUUPE!
Come on, you! Wanna play some more?
Screw you, buddy!
Okay...
Now if only there's a way to like, clear out the entirety of them.
Do I have any weapo--- oh, maybe this can pierce!
BOINK!!
Nope, doesn't seem to be doing that!
HOH HOO
Wow, those guys are being assholes.
Come on, pooshie! What are you doing with anything?
What are you doing with anything in helping me?
Okay, that guy..
Uh- is that even a poochie?!
Is that a gerbil?
Or something like that?
It doesn't quite look like a dog anymore.
More looks like an overgrown rat.
Hello...
Oh, these guys mean business! These guys are-
OHOOHHOOHHHOOO
WHOA WHOA who did that?
Who the hell?
Who the hell... is blasting up a storm over there?
WOW, these guys can take a lot of-
*BIG INHALE* NOOOOOOOO.
NOOOO. I JUST STARTED!!
Uh oh.
Well that's a- Oh okay.
Someone shot me good.. -little giggles in between-
The Ammomonicon?
AWWEEEHHH tits.
WELL that's the first death on my account, and that's because I got too cocky.
This time, I'll do a lot better --
Oh no, I'm back in Chamber 1?
Okay, I'ma blast through this as fast as I can.
I'ma get to Chamber 2, where I mean business.
Gimme gimme, what else do I got?
Crossbow? I'ma go with ---
Wooo.
*Stammering* Sorry, I-I-for some reason, I think 'space' is dodge?
But it's actually the right mouse button and that's what's throwing me off at the moment.
Yeah, I'm going to blame all my problems on everything else.
WOO that's a grenade!
oop!
hup!
Hopefully, I'll get something else other than the rail gun.
Not that it wasn't incredibly useful,
it just that it didn't seem to help me a lot because of how long it took to do that.
HELLO, I got a key!
Okay, maybe I WON'T fast-forward because I forgot that this is all randomly generated.
HIP! Sorry.
hip, wop-- WHOA!
HUP
No you don't!
How 'bout no?
hup!
Nope!
This doesn't seem to be doing a lot with little pittly arrows here.
Or maybe they can pierce his armor eventually...
AAH heheheheh
Okay, I'ma go back to the sidearm.
Hopefully above- like, over time you can eventually upgrade all of your shit.
Oh. You WERE a ghost, I didn't even know what you were!
Bullet?
The ghost of a bullet? Why do bullets have ghosts?
I don't know why I haven't questioned any of that before, but...
maybe because it's a video game and none of this makes any sense anyway...
So I can't go that way, not just yet...
But I can go this way...
Hello!
Anybody here wanna die?
Horribly?
Whoa! Don't do that!
HUP
There's a lot of you---
WOOOO hey heyy...
HO HO.
HEY HO HO.
HEY- WOO!
HEY HO.
Okay...
Aw man, that cover doesn't last very long, does it?
Man, there's so MANY OF YOU!!
woohohohohohho
Gotta show off some skill here!
YEEEEEHHH IT'S NOT ALL THAT difficult actually,
there's only three of them and I thought there were more.
Whoa- THAT'S NOT GOOD!!
AH BLUB!
BLUB BLUB BLU-- WHOAAAA.. blow up!
YAAAEY!
Whoa jeez, I'm still getting in a rumble.
Alright.. okay ...
Just gonna ...
change over here!
There you go!
Take some of this! Thank you!
There we go, they're dead.
Okay, so it's-it's,
It's awfully beneficial to switch to something a bit more hard-hitting
for the um, big guys, like my crossbow, so I can sa--
WHOA, HELLO!
That wasn't a letter!
That was nothing!
You're just pissed for no reason, buddy!
Oh, that-that is a four-leaf clover, what are you even doing with your life?
Where'd they go?
Hello?
Okay...?
Are they gone? Oh okay, I must've gott'em!
Go me! Go team go!
Okay. Holy shit!
Do it, I dare you!
huip huip
ooo
Okay.
Whoa... whoa what was th- oh ok.
Ooh! Blank!
I don't know how to use a blan- No, I do!
It's "Q" here, so I need to be more judicial about my blanks as well.
Hello!
Oooh, what is that?
OOOH!
'Phoenix - Reborn In Flame'
Is it like a flare gun or something? That's so cool!
Oooh this is cool!
[Evil laughter]
WHOAAAAAH!
That's awesome, I wanna use that!
I wanna use that on a hor-
poor, unsuspecting creatures of th-
Ow, what the hell? Where'd that ghost come from?
God dammit! Don-Don't do that!
Okay, so it's super close-range, but it does set them on fire.
Oh, god damn it!
All of a sudden, I started sucking as soon as I got a new gun.
No! No!
No!
Surprisingly effective for the slimes,
that's for damn sure.
Okay! Goodbye!
Hello?
Nope!
Ow! Why did you shoot first?
Ah, damn it! Why did he explode?
Ohh, there was a barrel by it.
Boink!
Sorry!
That's how the way the world works.
Hup!
Wooh!
Whoah! That guy shot himself!
I guess they ARE bullets, so...
makes sense.
Eegh!
I kinda don't like this gun, 'cause I gotta get so close to 'em?
Doggy, can you help me out here? I really need some help!
Apparently I'm doing very poorly.
Oooh, another one!
Hello?
Whoaaah!
That's a lotta stuff! What's this?
'Steady Aim'?
Nice!
Okay, cool for me!
Even though I'm about to die, eventually.
But I can still carry on.
I can do this!
I'm not gonna die yet, not without using everything that I need.
Yeah, see- I still like the gun better, just because...
it-it's super easy to stay at a distance and-
and at- being at a distance is very important in this game.
'Cause you goootta have room to react when they're gonna shoot at ya.
Another good thing about the game that I'll say is that the music is PHENOMENAL.
Like, this is super cool music.
Hello!
Like- um...
I-I've noticed there's a trend lately, there's a lot of like, pixelated-style games coming out.
One, because it's easier for developers to make
instead of focusing all the development on making like,
superior art acs- uh, art assests?
Whereas this one is different because it allows for...
like, much, much, much more refined game mechanics.
And that's where this game really shines. It's-
What the hell are you?
Get outta here! What do you think you're doing?
Oh! Wha- I lost a heart?
From shooting that guy!?
Oh, maybe I only bought one heart. I thought it gave me a full heart!
Ah, whatever.
See, the answer to that question is just, don't get shot as much. Stop being such a suck.
[Laughs] As Jack once told me, I'm such a giant massive suck.
I don't know how I end up getting at the boss room at the very end.
Hello!
You King Bullet?
How's it goin'? I'm here to kill you!
OHHHH aren't you just delightful?
Well, time to end your reign.
Oh, your whole chair is a guuhuhun- whoa, hey.
Ahhhkay...
Wooh!
Woow, poof, hep!
There we go... Haha!
Okay...
So what else you gonna do, what else is new?
Woooo, okay, that's new! Woooo, oookay!
Wo geez, woh geez, woh gersh, wo gersh
How is my poochie getting out of this okay?
I mean, I'm happy about it, but I'm just wondering what his survival secrets are.
Woh, garsh, oh gersh, oh gash... HOP, oh goddamn why'd I roll that way?
I was pointing upwards! It, it, it, like...
It rolls in the direction that you're moving, not always the direction that you're just facing
Which would make my life much easier.
This guy seems way harder than the other guy, I'm just gonna say that right now.
Trying to put out the big guns on 'em...
That's muuch more damage.
It's aah that stupid revolver is like the pittiliest little ti - whoop!
Little illy-bitty bits o' damage... See, it's always where you're going, not where you're aiming.
Which I which it wasn't...
Wooh... Getting cornered, getting cornered...
Whop! Hep! No, not into that, why would you do that?
Why would you do that?
Hop!
And there we go, you're DONE, baby!
I just blew up your chair, you're f- oh no, he's very dead *laughing*
Oh god, he blew up! In many ways! Not good.
Alright, what do we got here?
What are you?
"The People's Gun."
Oh good! It's just a better gun in general.
Hi!
*laughing* Oh-ho he's so sad!
Too bad!
Oh-ho-ho-ho, I didn't think that would actually do something!
*gasp*
Oh, I'm so evil!
Oh-ho, why did I kill 'em!?
Oh I killed 'em so dead.
Welp, oh well!
People will mourn another king another day.
I've got a level 2 dungeon to go through
and a less suck to do than thy-am-than-me.
Kaboom.
This game is so cool. If you haven't played it for yourself yet, go play it, it is...
Bonkers cool.
I just gotta get better used to the dodge because I-I got...
I wa- I was dodging up-
Woah! What the-
Woah (x7)
No thank y-
N- Woah!
Hey woah!
I don't like that!
Woah, hey, woah.
S-Snipers here.
'Scuse me no,
The answer is no.
Stop. Thank you.
Thank you for taking that guy out for me!
Good teamwork. Go team, go?
Okay.
Those guys su-u-u-u-u-ck!
Those guys ain't cool!
Oh, what are you!?
Oh God!
What is that?
Why is there an iron-
b- woah-ho-ho-ho-ho
*High pitched scream*
*laughing* Ho-ho-ho it's an enemy!
*laughing* I didn't know it was an enemy!
I thought it was just an object!
Oh God!
*screams*
*laughing* H-h-oh my God that's so- that's so scary!
Oh, that's so scary!
Heup!
Oh wow it's like-
This guy's a-
L-Oh shit! God dammit!
Oh God Dammit, I just used my burst!
I thought he was like a boss.
I thought he was like a mini-boss.
(stammering) Oh, you gelatinous cubes!
Oooh!
*laughing*
Oh I could've over-turned the tables, I totally forgot about that.
I keep forgetting to actually use the environment in my favor.
I need to be better about that.
Hello buddy.
Thank you.
Nope.
No-no-no-no-ooh.
This ga- this gun isn't much different than the revolver,
It's probably about the same damage as the revolver.
It's just um...
It's just a bigger clip size, which is good, question mark
I guess?
I don't know.
I'm gonna have to find out when I compare it later.
Oooh!
Hello, thank you!
What is you?!
Are you a can of soup?
"Shotga Cola"?
Oh, cool!
Nice.
What are you!?
Ooh I have a k- I had a key.
Aw, Goddammit
I had a key.
Oh, shit
Why did I do that?
Dammit
Not what I wanted.
You look like you could help me!
You look like interesting characters!
You look like people that I should meet in this adventure of mine!
You look so cool!
I just wanna be cool.
What a cool little stumpy arm you have on the left side!
Okay, bye then.
If I find a key, I'll come back to ya.
I found a key.
I thought I found a key in this round, but apparently not.
Oh, well, I'll find something else some other day...
No-No-No-No-No-Nu
Thank you.
Oh! That's unhelpful.
Hyep!
Maybe I can get them to shoot each other.
Would that be... possible?
Nope! Nope!
[mumbles] apparently not
Wooah!
Okay then!
He just wanted to give up on life.
Good to know.
Wait, was there something else over there?
I thought I saw something-
Woahuy!
Oh, no. No, no.
N- Oh, where am I?
Oh, I fell!?
Goddammit!
*screams* I fell again!
Goddammit I didn't see the pits!
Ahhh, don't do it.
Don't do it.
Well, that ends that one, so.
Oh, no, I got shot. I thought I fell, I was gonna fall anyways, so it's fine.
Okay! So that's all for this episode. I promise, I'll be better in the next one.
I just panicked in that room because I thought I was gonna get assaulted by snipers.
And I was!
And I got panicked into death.
So anyway,
I'll pick this up again, because this is super cool,
but let me know what you think of this in the comments below.
Let me know if you guys wanna see more of it, because I am VERY eager to play more of this.
So, thanks again, and as always...
I will see you, in the next video.
BUH-BYE!
*outro* :D